hey I'm Gary Vaynerchuk if you're seeing  this you haven't subscribed to my  YouTube you may know me from wine or  writing books or the cover of magazines  we're cursing on stage in a face mainly  I'm gonna focus on videos who can help  build your business I've helped you so  much  not drink crap wine keynotes and rants  and interviews and random and more I  love to pay forward not because I'm a  good guy because I like the leverage so  I'm just gonna give as much as I can on  this channel and then eventually one day  somehow you might owe me a favor  and follow me right now and let's call  it what it is you did not subscribe to  my YouTube channel before this moment do  you know how bad that feels do you know  what that hurts my soul my heritage my  grandmother is crying because of your  lack of subscribing to my youtube  channel  can't you just subscribe oh by the way  when you do email me ting yeah I want to  keep this thing let's keep the ting